the bills are where you want your team
to be most of your teams out there this
is where you want to be the bills and
part of the reason why is the man who's
calling in right now here on the rich
eisen show the quarterback of the
buffalo bills calling in on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line after a
big win against the kansas city chiefs
and getting set for monday night
football to end week number six
uh against the tennessee titans josh
allen back here on the rich eisen show
how are you josh
i'm doing good rich thanks for having me
on thanks for coming on uh how's life
how's life for you these days life's
good uh you know just uh just trying to
trying to get by each and every week
just seems like it gets uh shorter and
shorter and you know weeks go by and
blurs and sometimes
it's hard to remember who we're playing
but we we know we got tennessee titans
on monday night okay we can uh we got to
be ready for it i was going to help you
with that if they needed any help yeah
tennessee titans okay um so let's just
walk me through you see legeria sneed of
the kansas city chiefs and at what point
do you say i'll just jump over him how
does that work
well it's it was just one of those plays
a little little broken play that
i just kind of stepped up in the pocket
i felt it and understand the situation i
i knew we need to get to get a first
down didn't want to get the ball back to
them with the momentum that they had so
um i felt him go a little low and just
kind of
kind of said you know what here here it
goes if it works it works if not oh well
we'll see what we can do next play but
uh
it worked you know thank goodness and uh
we were able to move the ball and finish
that you know drive with the touchdown
so it was just a flash in your mind that
he's going low i need to go high i need
to go over him right that's how
literally as late as late as possible to
them it's just one of those decisions
where it's like
wait oh do it now you know it's just
your brain kind of goes into a scramble
and you really don't know what to do
while you're in the air
you're expecting somebody to come and
clip your leg you hope you don't fall
straight on your head but
um you know fortunate to kind of land on
two feet and dive a little forward to to
sustain a first down and sustain the
drive and um like i said i i want to do
anything i can do to help this team win
a football game and at that moment in
time that's what i thought was necessary
and i know what you said after the game
that it's just another game right that
it's one of 17 regular season games for
you this year but uh you know that was
also the place where your season ended
last year the photograph of your
uh compadre and teammate and friend uh
stefan diggs watching the celebration
and the confetti coming down wanting to
see it and use it uh it had to have
meant something that you took care of
business against the chiefs in such an
emphatic manner
on sunday night no
josh yeah it meant something to me we uh
we got our fourth win of the season
come mad come on i will not accept that
answer josh allen i will not accept that
answer come on as honestly it's honestly
all i can give you i know uh the story
lines of us playing there last year and
the pictures and the way our season
ended
um you know i think it was
it was awesome for our fans you know
they felt a sense of pride and
conviction when we won that game but
you know we got to turn our attention
towards the the tennessee titans because
you know they're playing really good
football right now and we gotta we gotta
be ready and to go into another hostile
environment um not only that we
understand that our bye week's the next
week so we can't get ahead of ourselves
so we got to focus on on the tennessee
titans on monday night in in nashville
um and be ready to play and so um
all that said uh josh what about a
measuring stick what about the fact like
okay that's the last two afc
championship
um you know winners right there and we
we beat him up i i had a great game my
teammates had a great game there's no
sense of that right now as you're
walking around your building you put a
little more pep in your step that you
did beat the team yeah there's
definitely a sense of confidence
um
you know any any time you can play a
team of that caliber and win the way we
did but again winning in the nfl isn't
easy you know it's uh it's a thing to be
celebrated you know for a limited amount
of time and then you got to turn your
attention and um you know what happened
on sunday night was was fun and awesome
you know we got in so late on uh on
monday morning five o'clock six o'clock
in the morning didn't get much sleep so
we got to try to recover and get back to
back to our normal schedule and like i
said be ready to go for tennessee josh
allen here prior to monday night
football against the tennessee titans to
wrap up week number six when did it
click for you
uh josh clearly you know the position
that you're in right now
uh confidence-wise team-wise contract
wise
um fresh off of an afc championship game
appearance wise super bowl ready-wise
that's what that was the plan when you
got the phone call from the buffalo
bills on draft day but when did things
begin to really click for you
where um
you are now an mvp candidate in the nfl
with extreme legitimacy josh when did
that happen for you well i mean i think
i got um
you know extremely confident in my
mechanics last year the offseason
having had covet i know the whole
situation was a little funky but being
able to be in the same situation the
same spot be able to throw
consistently week in and week out
with jordan palmer and with kyle and sam
you know digitally mapping my mechanics
just feeling good there and making sure
the ball's coming out as consistently as
possible i think that helps but again
being in the same system you know now
going on four years coach stable third
year with ken dorsey obviously with the
same
gm same head coach i think what you know
obviously what they're doing here in
buffalo and it's props to everybody in
the organization um you know i eat tim
and kerry or kim and terry for uh
putting together you know such an
awesome front office and coaching staff
and allowing players to come here and be
the best versions of themselves
and so what how does one digitally map
what what were you talking about was
what does that mean yeah there's we've
got a set up um
his name's chris haskey works for a
company called biometric and they set up
probably i think it's 12 12 or 13
cameras
and it just kind of shows
your peak velocities in your shoulder
your arm your hip your chest
um and it allows you to kind of measure
angular velocity and and things like
that so there is a sequencing of what a
throwing motion should look like
and before i was doing all this my
sequencing was way out of whack my arm
and my shoulder were beating my hip
to the punch and
you know that's just not great one for
arm care and two
consistently of ball placement so
being able to look at that data and
use it to my advantage change change
some things change my thought process on
the whole throwing motion
um you know it's extremely helpful when
i
i have such good talks with people about
throwing mechanics and it's uh it's
something i'm kind of nerding out on
it's uh obviously it's my life you know
it's what i do for a living and i want
to be as good as possible at it and uh
you know i've got had a lot of help
along the way and it's been really cool
and so who do you talk to about film
watching and things like that like about
improving neck up pre-snap type material
so sometimes you might not have to jump
over defenders things are taken care of
before you have to do that what about
that yeah that ken dorsey does a great
job
but again all the quarterbacks in the
room um mitch davis jake even going back
to last year matt barclay in the year
before derrick anderson just having a
guy like that who kind of showed me the
ropes of how to be
a professional a true nfl quarterback
taking walkthroughs seriously
understanding film you know how to
improve each and every year and i think
a big thing is just off season schedule
as a rookie
you know if you don't have somebody that
kind of tells you
you know it's on you you
you know you don't have spring ball you
don't have this you don't have that you
don't have to go to class you don't have
mandatory workouts so that's on you to
get better
and uh you know i think there's two guys
in this league guys that get figured out
and guys that figure it out um you know
it's better to be in that second
category josh allen here on the rich
eisen show a couple more minutes left
with the star quarterback in buffalo new
york when was the last time you paid for
a meal out and about in buffalo yeah
josh was the last one uh
you know i i don't actually like taking
three meals i i again being here in
buffalo i want to give back to the
community and the small businesses as
much as possible okay um so there's a
few times where i've been you know order
the mill but make sure i leave a pretty
nice tip you know because i want to give
back to the community
already given so much to me so it's uh
it is fun you know it's it's got got its
pros and cons of going out here you know
privacy really isn't a thing anymore
um but again the fans here are so
awesome they're so enthusiastic
and they love the bills here and it's uh
it's a sense of pride when we
can win football games for this fan base
and ultimately we want to win a super
bowl and give them that feeling we
understand 90 91 92 93
you know what we did um you know and we
didn't get it done so you know that
that's that's the goal for ours is to
bring this city a championship i love
that you said that look i know because
you're you're a blessed you know that
it's clear in just hearing your voice
and what you're saying you know you're
blessed and you know and i just want to
make sure
again khan when you say it's a con uh is
a pro to a con that you know you
understand that you're a blessed man but
it does take an adjustment that your
your newfound fame and
and fortune and also the the hopes that
people place in you in a rabid fan base
that takes some adjustment how about
that we already talked about mechanics
and film what about keeping your head on
straight who helps you with that yeah i
mean i think um one i feel like my
parents
were extremely
awesome really in how they raised my my
family
um they helped me keep my head on
straight my girlfriend brittany she does
a great job of helping me keep my head
on straight but
um you know i told myself if i was ever
in this position i wouldn't change the
type of person i was
um you know and i think really the main
con to
us the new found fame and all this and
it's just being recognized everywhere
and uh i'm such a low-key guy and i
don't like really be in the spotlight of
the tension
outside of the football field
obviously but
um you know i just want to live a normal
life and it's it's really hard to do
that i know it's
this is everything i've ever wished for
so i can't can't complain you know i i
made this bed i gotta lay in it
uh it's such a such a minor con
um but it does like you said take an
adjustment to getting used to
people coming up to you all the time
while you're eating and
not really again people driving by the
house and things of that nature and uh
that just i don't know if i'll ever get
used to but i understand why all right
do you want to rich eyes and show hat to
wear and pull over your your you know
your brow and help you go as incognito
as possible i'm i can do that that's
that's all i can tell you what you send
it i'll wear it i promise you that okay
josh allen i know you're addressed and
it's coming well clearly other people
know you're just too i didn't mean to i
didn't mean to say that i know that came
out terrible um
i'll send it through the bills and uh
and it's coming josh i'd like to see it
okay okay very good you got it well
that's what
hey that's that's my parting gift for
you for calling into the show thanks so
much josh uh continued success and let's
talk down the line
sounds good rich thank you god that's
right back at you that's uh buffalo
bills quarterback josh allen hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here